So, it turns out Thanos wasn't wrong when
he declared that there would be "no resurrections
this time" for Loki.
Still, that doesn't mean much where Infinity
Stones and trickster gods are concerned; Loki
manages something in Endgame with potentially
huge ramifications.
Spoilers from here on out!
Quick recap: When the Avengers go back in
time to get the Infinity Stones in Endgame,
one team heads to Stark Tower just after the
team has captured Loki in Avengers.
In part because of the interference of the
Avengers from the future, the captive Loki
gets his hands on the Tesseract and disappears
in a blue flash.
The big question is, where did he go?
The most immediate concern about Loki is whether
or not he creates an alternate timeline, split
off from the main MCU continuity, in which
he escapes the Avengers with the Tesseract.
When Captain America brings all the Stones
back to their respective times, does he return
everything to normal and stop any timelines
from branching?
Or is Loki still out there with the 2012 Tesseract?
If Loki does create an alternate timeline
when he escapes, and it still exists, then
that opens a whole world of possibilities.
Free from the Avengers and in possession of
the Space Stone, there's no limit to where
Loki might go.
He might bring the Tesseract to his benefactor
Thanos.
The Mad Titan's emissary, the Other, makes
it perfectly clear what Loki risks if he fails
Thanos, and none of it is pleasant.
"There will be no realm, no barren moon, no
crevice where he can not find you."
With the Chitauri forces Thanos gave to Loki
destroyed, the God of Mischief might see getting
the Tesseract back to the Titan as the only
way to save his life
However, Thanos probably wouldn't be Loki's
first stop.
Losing the Chitauri forces to the Avengers
would not necessarily sign Loki's death warrant.
But there's something we know now that we
didn't know when Avengers was released, that
Thanos gave Loki an Infinity Stone to get
an Infinity Stone.
He trusted the Mind Stone to Loki, and in
Endgame Loki leaves it behind when he escapes.
How does it help Thanos' plans if he gains
one Stone just to lose another?
Unless Loki is uncharacteristically foolish,
he won't run to Thanos.
Doing so would just get his neck broken six
years early.
Whatever deal was struck between Thanos and
Loki, it all happens off-screen.
We don't know the extent of Loki's knowledge
regarding Thanos, his plans, and his other
allies.
When Thor confronts Loki in Avengers, Loki
tells his brother he knows all about the Tesseract.
"I have seen worlds you've never known about.
I have grown, Odinson, in my exile.
I have seen the true power of the Tesseract."
So unless he's lying, he knows quite a bit.
If we assume by 2012 that Thanos and Ronan
the Accuser are already allies, and that Loki
knows about the alliance, Ronan could be Loki's
first stop.
At that point, Ronan is in no position to
challenge Thanos, and that's because he doesn't
know what Thanos is after.
When Thanos tasks the Kree with capturing
the Orb, Ronan doesn't know it contains the
Power Stone.
If Loki knows more about Thanos' machinations
than Ronan, then he has much to offer the
Kree warlord and a potential ally to protect
him from Thanos' wrath.
In the now classic mid-credits scene of Avengers
when Thanos is first revealed, the Other is
warning the Mad Titan against any further
action on Earth.
He tells his master that to challenge Earth
is to "court death."
If Loki guesses at this apprehension on the
part of Thanos' underlings to mess with Earth,
then the trickster might decide the best place
to be is right on Earth.
As long as he stays under the radar of the
Avengers, he could remain on Earth for as
long as he wants, with his own superhero enemies
acting as a shield against Thanos' wrath.
Or, alternatively, he could stay on Earth
with the intention of recapturing his scepter
to give it to Thanos.
Loki probably knows if he returns to Thanos
without both Infinity Stones, the Mad Titan
will do a lot worse to him than the Hulk ever
would.
In 2012, Loki's greatest weakness is his passion
for revenge.
With an Infinity Stone at his command and
his knowledge of the secret ways into and
out of Asgard, his first trip after Endgame
might be back home to claim what he sees as
his rightful throne.
In the proper MCU timeline, he doesn't have
to worry about Thanos; Loki's failure to conquer
Earth leads him straight to an Asgardian dungeon.
As soon as he escapes in Thor: The Dark World,
he fakes his own death and disguises himself
as Odin.
The disguise allows him to rule Asgard, yes,
but it has the added bonus of hiding him from
Thanos.
What's easier than conquering a world ruled
by your adoptive family?
Conquering a world ruled by no one, of course.
After 2011's Thor, we don't hear much from
Jotunheim, the land of the Frost Giants.
Thor and Malekith visit it briefly and involuntarily
during their battle in 2013's Thor: The Dark
World, but we don't exactly get a good picture
of the political situation there.
We know after initially offering to help assassinate
Odin, Loki betrays and murders his biological
father, and then he attempts to use the bifrost
to destroy the frost giants' world.
"It was just a bit of fun really."
So, when Loki escapes the Avengers in Endgame
and needs a place to hang his horned hat,
a potentially leaderless Jotunheim might be
the perfect choice, and the throne could be
his for the taking.
He is the biological son of their dead king,
and he has an Infinity Stone to back up his
claim.
Not to mention that with intimate knowledge
of Asgard and its most powerful leaders, he's
in a unique position to satisfy any frost
giants hungry to make war on Odin once more.
The mid-credits scene of Thor: The Dark World
sees Sif and Volstagg sent to Knowhere to
deliver the Aether to the Collector.
It's one of the most deceptively important
moments in the MCU, because of this line:
"The Tesseract is already on Asgard.
It's unwise to keep two infinity stones so
close together."
Without some as-of-yet unrevealed connection
between Loki and the Collector, it's a moment
that doesn't make much sense.
It's Loki disguised as Odin who sends the
Aether to Knowhere, and the power hungry Loki
is not someone we expect to send an Infinity
Stone to someone else.
Not unless there's a plan behind it all.
A connection between the Collector and Loki
could also explain the Grandmaster's friendship
with the trickster in Thor: Ragnarok, as Grandmaster
and the Collector are brothers.
If this connection between the Collector and
Loki ever proves to be more than speculation,
then it could be that Knowhere was Loki's
first stop after Endgame.
Although, granted, that's one of the least
likely outcomes.
One thing that's easy to forget about Loki
is that, before Thanos finally rounds them
up in Avengers: Infinity War, Loki has more
encounters with more Infinity Stones than
anyone in the MCU.
In Avengers, he possesses both the Mind Stone
and the Tesseract.
After usurping Odin at the end of Thor: The
Dark World, he has access to the Reality Stone
until he sends it to Knowhere, and has as
much access as he wants to the Space Stone.
Loki knows the Infinity Stones, at least,
he knows something about them.
We don't know how much, if anything, Thanos
tells him about them, but the trickster god
has a way of getting information whether you
want him to or not.
Armed with the Infinity Stone that has the
power to bring him anywhere, Loki may decide
to go on an Infinity Stone quest of his own.
Not only would the completion of such an endeavor
feed his hunger for power, but again, would
provide him with the muscle to destroy Thanos
should the Titan come for his vengeance.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.